it shows that we're live brother now
it'll take a second to for people to
start uh filtering in and watching let's
see I got my lovely assistant hitting
Refresh on her screens to see when it
starts so give us just half a second you
bet all right it shows me live on
YouTube and it shows me let's see how we
look on Rumble let me hit the little
refresh we're live we're live on both
brother Lieutenant Colonel Matthew L
former Lieutenant Colonel to people who
aren't familiar with your story they're
about to be blown away um I've had the
pleasure of meeting you a couple times
now and as a former uh serviceman I
couldn't be more proud of you uh when we
met I was going to tell you that but I
didn't want to make it awkward but you
are the definition of a leader who chose
to do the hard right instead of the easy
wrong and so I'd like to basically start
this off with you sharing who you are
what happened I I have no doubt that
there's some people watching this that
are familiar with your story but I bet
you most people have not heard of it
it's a story that is growing it's been
going on for a couple years now um but
it's pretty wild and you have this
unbelievably important insight into a
number of different topics so to anyone
not familiar with Lieutenant Colonel
Matthew ler who or prior because you've
been out since September of 2001 um but
you were a commander in the unit States
space force you're a prior US Air Force
fighter pilot as well as trainer uh you
flew the F-15 which is one of the most
sophisticated fastest jets out there
that's the that's the big guy that they
give to the top Pilots if we're being
honest because what it goes what three
400 miles an hour faster than like an
F-16 what's the numbers on that in every
way the F-15 is better than the F-16
yeah we're going to get into that and uh
of course whenever somebody is talking
to somebody if they were to talk to
somebody from the United States space
force I'm inclined to think that the one
of the first questions they're going to
going to want to ask is related to UFOs
uaps and aliens so we're definitely
going to get into that to everyone
watching we are streaming simultaneously
right now on Rumble and on YouTube and
in a half hour or 45 minutes or so we'll
jump over to rumble that's a you know
and let me just say this real quick if
you guys are wondering or people
watching like why w i just stay on
YouTube Rumble is promoting my contact
uh cont content unlike YouTube I'm very
happy with YouTube YouTube's been very
good to me but to just let me just say
this real quick and I want to give you
the stage because you have a lot to say
um I have like 1.6 million followers on
YouTube and my last live stream got
100,000 whereas on Rumble I have 880,000
and I have almost 300,000 views they put
my content on the front page you go to
rumble.com and they blast it so to
anyone listening the link Down Below in
the description you'll that's all you'll
have to hit once we leave YouTube to go
over to rumble to finish our our
conversation and basically that's what
I'm I'm telling you is that we're going
to get into the aliens over on Rumble
but right now we'll start off here so
without further Ado Matt uh will you
please tell us basically a little bit
about your background and your story um
and I'm I'm sure everyone's going to be
fascinated what they're about to
hear well Jimmy my wife and I are
subscribers to your bright insights
YouTube channel have been for a long
time and um I was just as happy to meet
you in person as you were me um we've
learned a lot and have interest in the
things that you've been talking about
for a long time even though it seems a
little bit out of the uh purview of a
space force or an Air Force officer it's
all fascinating nonetheless and um so
thanks for all of your work
um I was just in the Nashville Tennessee
airport um two days ago and as I was
waiting to board my flight I sat next to
a woman uh who wanted to strike up a
conversation with me and as I chatted
with her she asked uh what I did for a
living and that inevitably led to a
conversation about my military career
and when you mention to anyone that you
were in the space force they look at you
kind of funny uh like they don't know
what you're talking about and I suspect
um that your listener audience is a bit
more astute than your
average American citizen uh nevertheless
I'll start there and just say that there
is a branch of the military called the
United States space force it uh is in
fact written into title 10 of the US
code as of December 2019 it's an
official branch of the military it's the
first time that we created a branch of
the military since
1947 uh when we last stood up a branch
of the military which is the US space
force I sorry the US Air Force um when I
finished flying jets in 2013
I came
to uh the US Air Force space command and
in the Air Force space command uh we do
um space related missions such as GPS
space-based missile warning strategic
Communications and whatnot and when the
new branch of the military the space
force stood
up we essentially did an organizational
restructure uh renamed a bunch of units
but all of those missions that Air Force
once did in and through and from space
the newest branch of the military the
space force also uh took responsibility
for and just continued doing those same
old missions that we had always done in
the Air Force um and so uh what whatever
little uh knows about what the Air Force
did in Space the space force is also
doing uh those things that said there
are new missions that our newest branch
of the military is doing that the
American people haven't yet heard about
uh new new units have been stood up uh
some of my my peers that I know well
were placed in charge of units to do
missions that are still highly
classified and that I'm sure in the five
and 10 years ahead uh they'll learn more
about publicly but yeah you've you've
summed up my background I spent over 15
years in the department of the Air Force
uh in both of those Services flu Jets I
was a t38 instructor pilot as well and
uh grew up in Tucson Arizona right
nearby where you live um don't know if
that's knowledge or not but um so yeah
that's uh a high level overview of my
background now I'm gonna go ahead and
flatter you and and and drop you know do
the whole name dropping thing you have
met Elon Musk you you briefed him you've
also briefed then president Trump um and
a lot of people should understand that
you know what happened to you in the
military as you're about to get into you
were and I'll go and say it you were ear
marked for en like you got taken in
under assistant under a general directly
correct and that's something people
they're essentially train I was I was an
aid to Camp uh is what it's called for
the fourstar general who was in charge
of Air Force space command and then
became the first Chief of space
operations which is a member of The
Joint Chiefs and who is the fourstar
general in charge of the space
force I see
now you started me clarify something Jim
say so a lot of people that follow me
are aware that I was enlisted and I had
deployed to Iraq I had volunteered I was
very patriotic after 911 uh I was a
senior in high school when 911 happened
so I was profoundly affected I went into
a recruiter's office shortly thereafter
end up having a few knee surgeries and
it held me back and finally in 2006 I
enlisted and volunteered to go to Iraq
and finally I was placed in a unit that
eventually got there in 2009 and what I
know being in the military is that there
is no place like genders don't matter
your first name doesn't even matter you
are it's business it's a very
professional setting and so you started
observing
um protocol that deviated away from that
what you share just be blunt share what
you started observing happening
involving the your time and service
whether it's we're going to dive into
Marxism we're going to dive into CRT and
gender and everything else um share what
you
observed well
we've got a lot to talk about I think uh
and this is just one topic of many um
I'll try and share high level thoughts
if you want me to go deeper then feel
free to interject and um ask
more um I went to the
dod's premier strategy School in 2019 to
get a master's degree in military
strategy we studied a lot of history uh
War Theory
the history of the Cold War and I became
somewhat enamored during the year that I
was there with the history of marxist
revolutions and communism and
um I uh came out of that school into
command in the space force in the summer
of
2020 and that was at Buckley Air Force
Base now Buckley space Force Base
outside of uh Denver Colorado and after
I arrived there in command I uh
immediately recognized that there was a
totalitarian Spirit a foot on the base
because we had a a leftwing activist
base commander who wittingly or not had
adopted into his
um into his daily walk a Marxist
Narrative of human events and of the
history of the United States uh he had
adopted the New York Times 1619 project
as his view of History which he wanted
to help help educate all of our base
service members about and so he was
trying to disabuse us of the idea that
the country in fact had a founding in
1776 and wanted to inform us instead
that our country's founding began with
the instantiation of of of slavery in
the United States but the the reason I
bring all of that up is because I
recognized at once that a lot of his
talking
points were all about a Narrative of an
oppressor and his narrative was
race-based it was an oppressor who was
white and an oppressed who was black and
that the white black divide the
oppressor versus the oppressed narrative
that marks so well uh outlines in part
one of the Communist
Manifesto uh what was was something that
was really important to him as a uh
radical political activist base
commander that he inject into the B
culture to help help I guess re-educate
all of us and it's not just Air Force
personnel or space Force personnel there
were at that base there's Navy personnel
and army personnel and other
three-letter agencies at Buckley doing
space missions and so that's my first
encounter with what I saw as political
activism uh from senior ranks may I ask
you really quick this this Commander was
a white dude correct no no he was a he
was a black man okay uh and I'll tell
you to your
point um your first name didn't even
matter in the military for the entire
time you were serving in the in the
uniform that I was serving in uniform um
certainly your political views didn't
matter uh your race didn't matter and it
didn't matter ever if you had a white
Commander leading black Airman or you
had a black Commander leading white
Airmen that wasn't something that people
cared about because you expected a
talented thoughtful leader to help you
understand your mission in a broader
context that was maybe geopolitical
maybe it was there's certain political
aims to which your mission was attached
and it was all in defense of the nation
and the Constitution and the American
ideal our way of life our
freedoms and um that had all almost with
a bang after George Floyd's death gone
out the window and the activism that you
saw spreading across the United
States on the Nightly News was the kind
of activism that was coming from my base
commander and I recognized it at once as
unacceptable behavior for someone who is
in uniform and so I took on
the it was a slow realization it was
months in the making but I realized that
this is this is unacceptable enough that
it requires feedback it requires a
formal written complaint to the space
force inspector General's office it
required talking to members of The Joint
Chiefs my old boss included uh president
Trump uh shortly after I began this
conversation in September of 2020 issued
an executive order Banning the teaching
of critical race Theory and and the
Banning of diversity in inclusion
trainings in the military and um that
stopped all of the political activism
RIT large throughout the defense
Department with the exception of a few
small Pockets I suppose and one of those
fortunately and unfortunately was my
base at Buckley I had a guy who couldn't
help himself uh I also had an activist
CH chaplain who did his bidding and who
couldn't help himself but denigrate the
United States and the white man which
was totally unacceptable so that led to
a bunch of things so just to clarify
these leaders were knowingly and
purposely
disobeying an order from the president
of the United States the
commander-in-chief by knowing purp okay
yes but
craftily they uh they proceeded with
their indoctrination so as to be able to
deny that they were wittingly uh or
purposefully indoctrinating and subverse
an entire base population if you were to
ask my base commander you know does he
believe in Marxism he'd probably scratch
his head and say I'm not sure what you
mean by that and he genuinely might not
have but um that's one of the reasons I
thereafter wrote a book trying to help
educate the uh hey I was just reading it
too by the way before we jumped on this
call because I forgot what I wrote in
there it you weren't kidding like people
uh have resly in the reviews called this
the best description of Marxism that
they've ever heard and it matters more
now than ever most people don't actually
know what Marxism is uh they they're
like well communism what's this what's
that will you explain that and then and
then we'll get into like what happened
to you after you wrote this but would
you give the The Listener right now
explain to us exactly what Marxism is
and how we're seeing it in our lives and
how we've seen it as well as throughout
history and how you know it's reemerging
you know so it's so tough to um I kind
of really dislike um
mainstream media the big the big news
shows because if I'm asked to go on
there I get 60 seconds describe things
and so I very much better appreciate a
podcast like yours where I can I can
take a little bit of time at least but
that that's why things like this
questions like this do require a book
sometimes is because it's difficult for
someone who's never grappled with these
ideas to in an instant start to absorb
them but I'm going to try and be as
succinct and real and true as possible
so that hopefully it's helpful for
someone who's not thought through this
before
communism predates Carl Marx okay
communism and a communist
League asked Carl Marx if he would pen a
declaration or a Manifesto for them that
would State articulately their views and
Carl Marx uh published what is now known
as The Communist Manifesto what what we
all recognize and have heard of as the
Communist Manifesto A century and a half
ago with the help of friederick Engles
and it has four parts in it and in those
four parts of the Communist Manifesto
Marx wrote his young bright ideas down
about how he best thought it was
possible to incite the working class in
his Day to a violent revolution against
the
bisi he divided up his Narrative of
human events into two groups an
oppressor class this is all in part one
of the Communist Manifesto and an
oppressed class that was respectively
the Bourgeois and the
proletariat and he gave the proletariat
sufficient reason in the
manifesto that they needed to unite as
workers and if necessary violently throw
off their oppressor the modern
capitalist okay so as a starting place
and I and if someone wants to look into
this more I've described it fairly well
I think in part two of my book
irresistible reolution it's it's in part
two where you can go I go through in
detail all four parts of marxist
Communist Manifesto but the difference
between
Marxism which is an ideology it's a
thought about communism and about
violent revolution and about the
oppressor versus the oppressed classes
and communism is just that it's the it
Marxism is the thought of Carl Marx
about socialism communism and it's about
economy yes it is but it's also a much
broader view of of human events that
I've already described as the oppressor
versus the oppressed communism is a form
of government where the government has
seized all control of um of uh of
economy uh uh the means of production
and is um is something there's lit
literally a thousand videos available or
there's 10,000 videos available um on on
communism and communist countries that
you can go look at after this but
Marxism is the thought of the man Carl
Marx the apologist for Marxism will want
to tell you well it's really all about
economy and Carl Marx admittedly wrote a
lot about economies he wrote a little
bit about it in Communist Manifesto but
he wrote a lot about it in Das capital
and elsewhere and one of the things that
I saw when I began to study Marxism the
ideology that was permeating all of the
countries across the globe
in the late 19th century and surely
throughout all of the Cold War was that
there was an emphasis on pitting one
class or group of people for whatever
reason early on in the 19th century mid
to late 19th century is about economic
class
stratification later it was usurped and
today it has been usurped to be about
race relations and an oppressor class
versus an oppress group or or class of
people because it the spirit of it all
is the same but the narrative has been
adopted to our modern circumstances in
the United States because it's the best
Narrative of human events that can be
leveraged to create anger and hatred
sufficient to to get people to unite
together in violence against the other
the evil other okay that is the that is
what I want to emphasize about this so
as a starting point I'll say that is
Marxist ideology or Marxist thought the
the idea in the end is that it brings
about a Revolution that will allow for a
communist state to be uh established the
first successful Revolution by the way
that led to a successful establishment
of a communist state was the Bolshevik
Revolution uh that was little over one
century ago now in Russia and uh within
like two years or three years there were
over a hundred communist parties
established in countries across the
globe to include our very own United
States it was like 1919 or 1920 that we
had a Communist Party us say that wasn't
exceptionally popular but uh it was
active and it became popular so the
purpose of this is what's the underlying
purpose it's not that these people want
to uh give jobs to people and make
things equal isn't it about the people
at the very top just want to dominate
and control isn't that what the all this
woke culture is ultimately about isn't
that what it is is that the people at
the top don't actually believe in it
they don't practice it they're the
biggest hypocrits on planet Earth uh
what's their why do they do it well well
that's it's a tough question
um because the Nuance matters and uh
there's no one- siiz fits-all answer but
I want to re-emphasize something you
said in your question and it's that
wokeism and Marxism and postmodernism
and feminism and lgbtq ISM and all of
the isms and the causes and the and the
social justice Affairs in which Humanity
has been involved for decades now uh
black pride I mean I not I'm not meaning
to give offense to anyone but at this
point I don't really care because all of
these isms are really connected to the
spirit of Marxism which in my book I try
to show was the spirit
that animated the Illuminati in the
century prior to Marx with Adam viop and
others leading up to I mean Adam viop I
think dies in 1830 perhaps and it's the
same year that KL Marx
is uh I might get that wrong 1820 1830
but I mean they barely they they almost
overlap and I think it's most
appropriate frankly to take the spirit
of the ideology all the way back to the
beginning of recorded history you can
see it show up in a Genesis account
whether you view it as a literal history
or mythology of Cain and Abel you've
got you've got an adversarial
Spirit whispering in a man's ear you've
been dealt with unjust ly you've been
treated
wrongfully your brother has taken
something that rightly belongs to you in
this case the birthright and if you use
violence you can take what rightly
belongs to you that's the spirit of Cain
and I think that that same spirit that
emotional visceral response in anger and
hatred to your
brother that the enemy has whispered in
your your ear that that shows up there
in Genesis is the very same Spirit
that's been used to topple regimes
throughout history and it has different
names and it wears different masks and
Marxism wears different masks goes by
different names um and I don't care if
it's the black lives matter movement in
2015 and 2018 and then
2020 um the the impulse of anger that
leads to violence because you've been
dealt with
unjustly that uh a bunch of homies
wearing wife beaters in the streets of
Chicago exhibit when they're smashing
windows and tearing down and burning
down Society is the very same Spirit
that's been since the beginning I want
to be clear about that and understanding
that I thought man you can never do this
narrative Justice unless you like lay it
out a little bit in a book right and so
right uh with a bit of a chip on my
shoulder and begrudgingly I I put pen to
paper trying to describe this a little
little bit in a
book as best I could and pointing people
to other sources um and I think it I
think I did a pretty good job and I
think it's led to at very
least a bit more of a national dialogue
about what we're
suffering in the uniform services as a
consequence of this kind of rhetoric
about the evils of America now don't get
me wrong I want to be clear too like I
mean I just went to the uh the Black
Hills and went to see Mount Rushmore for
the first time in my life like six
months ago and on paper I've always
thought man that's like American
exceptionalism and I got there and it
really bugged me I looked at the
chiseled out mountain and I thought well
that's pretty disrespectful and I don't
think George Washington and Thomas
Jefferson would have uh is Jefferson up
there I know Washington is AB Lincoln
Tedd Ted Teddy Roosevelt but you know
like I looked at those guys and I
thought I don't think Washington would
have wanted his face carved on the
Native American Black Hills sacred
mountain right and so like I'm very real
about the evils of
Empire um and the United States uh
suffers from the evils of statecraft
like any other Empire in human history
I'm staring at my volumes of the decline
and fall of the Roman Empire in front of
me I
mean yes that's a very real part of the
unfolding history of human drama but
America's ideals are great uh American
exceptionalism is rooted in the ideas
and ideal ideals that our Founders tried
to ensure in the form of a declaration
of independence and in a constitution
it's for those ideas and ideals that we
fought the Civil War I think and it's
for those ideas and ideals that you had
the great oratory of a Martin Luther
King Jr or other Champions real
champions of civil Liber Liberties and
we undo all of that When Fools Rush In
trying to solve problems that have
already been solved and our adamant that
um that we're just so evil that we must
be toppled and so we topple statues we
burn cities and we um destroy buildings
and I'll tell you what and then I'll
stop but you what what I saw in command
in a unit in the space force was a base
commander who was parting Marxist
narratives of American
history and I saw young people who are
18 and 19 and 20 and 21 getting on their
Twitter accounts and on their uh what's
the highly compromised maybe well
they're all compromised Tik Tock getting
on their Tik Tok accounts or Instagram
accounts and they were pushing this
narrative out because that's what they
saw others doing and they just wanted to
retweet and they wanted to send out a
Tik Tok video and so when you have young
men and women who have signed up to
serve their
country but are also in their free time
parting black lives matter and saying
that they hope that Detroit Burns to the
ground or Baltimore Burns To The Ground
first off they should be court marshaled
and kicked out of the service but they
weren't and they were protected and so I
knew instantly we'd created a sufficient
cultural problem for ourselves that
unless it was undone quickly we'd likely
see the
of massive amount of Americans from
service in their in their military which
we have and we'd run into terrible
retention problems too we'd what we'd
see people leaving the military services
we've seen that do you believe that's
intentional like I look at everything
the military is doing it's almost like
they're trying to make people not want
to join like all my fellow veterans
everyone's confused like people are you
know people I served with which has now
been 13 years ago since I've been out of
the service or 11 years ago since I've
been out excuse me um everyone's like
looking around like what's happening
it's almost like they're trying
to level out the the United States
military to become such a a weak force
that we will not be able to defend
ourselves let let me ask you this let me
just be Point Blank do you believe that
we have been infiltrated do you believe
the United States has been infiltrated
and you believe that um and if so why
and what's the uh where's this heading
let's get let's get into this what
what's really what do you think is
happening so you have all this
experience you wrote a book about this
they relieved you of your command um
you're essentially fired is what they
did to you you exposed they're doing
drag time Story Hour on base correct
yeah drag time Story Hour um is
permissible but not someone who's an
enemy of Marxism apparently and uh you
know here's the height of
irony the amount of blood and treasure
that this country spent to combat
communism and to contain Marxist thought
during the Cold War a half century of
fighting the Korean and Vietnam Wars are
the ones people mostly pay attention to
because it's the only ones the United
States have had a
really involved participation in but
there were wars fought with
marxists in countries all over the world
during the same time
frame and it's over at the beginning of
the
90s
and it's like the the great Beast of
Communism is behind us so we think and
we're sitting high and mighty as the
global hedgemon and we think all is well
and we're comfortable and our enem is
actively working in the universities of
course they had been for a long time but
also in the United States military the
answer to your question is yes we've
been infiltrated at every in every
institution at the highest levels of
government that's been demonstrated it's
not just a theory it's been demonstrated
that we've
been infiltrated however so that's the
simple answer but I really squirm a
little bit when I'm the one I like
listening to simple answer sometimes but
I want to be careful with what I say I
don't think that everyone who
participates in the Revolutionary fervor
is a
witting a vowed Marxist I don't believe
just impressionable and going and
fitting in right isn't that what a lot
of people do they go after the young
ones because like more than anything
kids just want to fit in young
impressionable adults I should call them
kids like even people in their very
early 20s are still kids in my mind
because they're still figuring
themselves out and I think that one
thing if anyone has noticed anything
last few years is that more than
anything people just they don't want to
be ridiculed a lot of people know that
things are messed up right now and a lot
of people won't speak up out of fear of
just having their friends be like what
are you conspiracy theorist bro stuff
like that well I saw you take you took
heat recently uh you asked some question
on Twitter like a couple weeks ago about
Hitler yeah and now you're a Nazi all of
a sudden right I me so genuine listening
like so I recently went to Balck Lebanon
just a month ago actually and I'm making
a video on it it's going to be
spectacular I have pictures of the
trilon stones the largest Stones ever
cut carve moved and and stacked in human
history uh total mystery it's my in my
mind it is arguably the best example of
a lost ancient civilization that there
is and I'm going to present so um and
what's interesting is at this site which
is quite mysterious by the way there was
uh Rose Granite that was brought all the
way from Aswan Egypt
over to Lebanon at the S of Balck and
that's like 800 miles as the bird flies
and not only that they would have had to
move these stones that were tens of tons
for the columns the pieces of the
columns and they brought up a mountain
like the the Lebanese the Lebanon Mount
Lebanon excuse me or the Lebanon
mountains is an average height of uh
6,000 feet but the Peaks top at over
10,000 feet and they brought them up
there um it's a real mystery um but
anyways at this spe spectacular site
there are numerous swastikas now this is
before the swasa and it went by a number
of different names uh it's argued
originated in Ancient India but there's
you know it's been found all over the
world in fact the Native Americans have
that same symbol the H Indians of
Arizona and other uh uh tribes as well
um I'm making a video on that so what I
asked was because I found it incredibly
interesting that Hitler let me just say
it I gotta say it [__] Hitler like if I
could go back in time I would have been
the one that shot him like I literally
volunteered to go to Iraq because I
thought that liberating liberating the
Iraqi people was like the you know get
rid of Saddam and his sons and like
you're there's a modern day Hitler so
like I I feel like I shouldn't even have
to say that but like nowadays you kind
of almost got a preface it like I would
shoot Hitler if I could um but before I
would have done that I would have wanted
to get some answers out of him what as
to why he was unbelievably fascinated
with ancient civilizations why did he
and the Reich put in enormous resources
into looking for the um
uh the ark of the covenant the Holy
Grail even Thor's hammer this is people
should read about this this isn't
Indiana Jones those movies were based
off of historical events and that the
Nazis were actually looking for these
artifacts and I want to know why because
out of how evil the Nazis were they were
unbelievably sophisticated arguably the
the most educated country on Earth at
that time they invented the CH the jet
engine they created the Volkswagen Bug
they Creed the microphone there this was
an unbelievably sophisticated
civilization and I want to know why they
were so interested in archaeology um and
anyway so I made some post on Twitter
showing literally the swasa even though
it's not the swasa in front of you know
these at these temples and I was asking
I was like why did Hitler and the Nazis
know something about lost ancient
civilizations that we don't and then all
these academics came after' be like
you're a Nazi you're pushing Nazis I'm
like what are you talking about I'm like
I'm asking a question here of historical
significance um but that's the world
live in now you can't you can't talk
about anything without having people I
make videos talking about the pyramids
and and people tell me that I'm denying
Egyptian history it's like you can't ask
questions anymore but um I didn't mean
to cut you off there but people need to
hear this like this I recently went
through this and to be honest I'm just a
fighter like I I don't care as much as
some people would and I kind of Thrive
when people are coming after me a little
bit and especially when you know that
you're in the right I'm like me asking
why was Hitler looking for the Ark of
the Covenant that's a legitimate
question let's focus on the
it's legitimate yeah well it's a
legitimate question it's fascinating to
me as well frankly you know we talk
about these ugly things like Marxism but
I'd rather go watch your next video on
uh what you found in
Lebanon yeah yeah Lebanon um I'm telling
you I had made a video on this a few
years ago now so now it's time to redo
it and I'm so grateful that I went out
there especially the timing of it
because now we're seeing what's
happening in the world um you have
Hezbollah so in Balck it's run by
Hezbollah they're the government they
they run the show you have to go through
checkpoints um we took special
precautions to go and um I'm so grateful
I got out there when I did because the
way you know Hezbollah is talking about
going into Israel there's all kinds of
crazy things going on so I'm
unbelievably fortunate at the timing of
it um but let's just let's get into some
juicy stuff here um okay so you're at
the space force let me just ask you list
because like let me just be a nerd for a
seconds um so you flew the F4 or excuse
me the F-15 and you went on to train
people in the F1 so F-15 is the big boy
and I like I'm an airplane nerd um I I'm
really into Jets a lot of people aren't
aware that I used to take flight lessons
and I was going to be a commercial
airline pilot and then I end up deciding
to do a rock instead and um it ended up
not being the the profession for me like
I had a buddy that went down the
commercial airline route and it just I
realized quickly it's like they take all
the fun out of flying like it's just
it's a freaking job and and you for
years you start out doing the crummy
flights but anyways that F-15 so what's
the fastest you've ever
been you know yeah okay I'm going to
answer that I want to answer I want to
make one other comment um please I I'm
still stuck on what you said a minute
ago about I just I'm thinking about how
easy it is for people online to
criticize your curiosity and the
questions that you'd
ask uh you know YouTube for
example um is quick to remove a video
that makes any reference to Hitler as if
like you have to have some official
History Channel or something where
you're doing a really careful academic
Deep dive if you want your content to
remain on uh YouTube I wouldn't be
surprised if I I talked about on one of
my old podcast episodes I only did my
podcast for like four
months uh about the Nazis for a few
minutes and and that episode was removed
uh from YouTube the real Nazis in Spirit
uh today are those who seem to be
screaming there's like this inner
totalitarian that's screaming to get out
and they're the first to accuse and
ridicule and shame you for being curious
about world history they're the they're
the people sitting in the halls of
Congress right now who want to shame
Israel for defending itself against the
brutal attacks of Hamas that I
mean people I didn't mean to cut you off
it's that's okay but those are that's
the Nazi Spirit um it's the totalitarian
spirit and na ISM and
communism
um are are both evils and we should be
able to talk about those things and be
curious about those things so uh but o
overmach 1 is the fastest I've gone in
an F-15 it's a super sonic aircraft uh
you w't that hit Mach 2 no I never hit
Mach 2 uh you'd be in a dangerous spot
if you hit Mach 2 in an F-15 but okay
the super Cruise that's available on
like the the the F20 2 means that you're
able to break the sound barrier without
putting your aircraft into
afterburner uh f-15s and the other
fourth gen Fighters uh require you to
tap After Burner to break the sound
barrier and so uh if you're either
running away or to a fight and you need
to lob uh the am Rams down range then
you'll fly a supersonic flight profile
at a
certain angle of attack and launch your
missiles and then you'll you'll turn and
and run away and that's about the only
times you'll be an afterburner unless
you're in a close engagement dog fight
uh to be clear I didn't see combat in
those envelopes but you train every
single day in those envelopes and so you
become very familiar with them and uh
you know what the speed of sound sounds
like when you break the speed of sound
in an
F-15 absolutely
nothing just
like yeah it's it's no different you see
the you see your uh your your your
instruments um jump and bounce a little
bit momentarily oh really um when you
you know the loudest uh part of the
flight
envelope in an F15 is when you're at
corner velocity at high G uh and there
are certain diagrams that we reference
that tell you exactly uh what air speeds
to fly at what altitudes uh and certain
under certain G load and uh if you're
flying at corn ofoc vity pulling G in
the F-15 it sounds like the Roar of a
lion and you can hear that inside the
cockpit it's awesome I bet it's wild it
is I just saw a comment someone's asking
about the tr3b so here's the deal we're
40 minutes in at this time we're gonna
move this over to rumble and I want to
jump into the big questions I'm gonna
ask you about the tr3b first I'm gonna
ask you have you ever seen a don't
answer right now don't even nod uh
everyone the link is in the description
it's on Rumble it's it's streaming for
rumble it's streaming there
simultaneously right now we're going to
move it over there we're going to get
into the the real juicy questions I'm
going to ask about UFOs I'm going to ask
if you've ever seen anything I'm going
to ask if you believe that the
government is hiding anything I'm gonna
I also want to ask you well I got a
number of questions I want to ask you
the most provocative things of all so at
this time we're going to move this over
to rumble so hey everybody on YouTube
hit the link right down there in the
description um for those of you who
aren't coming with us although you
should because we're going to get into
the good stuff go on Amazon and buy
irresistible Revolution support Matt
like the one of the points I was getting
at earlier when I was mentioning that he
was earmarked for General they make like
almost $20,000 a month like like or I
don't know like 16 17,000 un last I saw
base pay that doesn't include housing
and the the gde and like everything else
like these guys like this is like a
really uh a comfortable lifestyle in
retirement and you and you gave all that
up you knew what was happening when you
did it you you knew that by calling out
these people it was gonna come back at
you and you sacrificed everything and
like I said you did the hard right
instead of the easy wrong so I want
people to realize like there were a few
people people in this world that are
willing to stand up and do the right
thing and speak out like more than
anything people need to speak out when
they see something wrong and you're the
guy that did it and I deeply respect
that and so I'd encourage other people
uh to support you in your cause and I
know there's other things you can't get
into but there's movies and other things
being worked on to help get this story
out um but at this time I'm going to hit
end on the YouTube live stream everyone
just hit the link in the description for
rumble it's streaming there
simultaneously so at this time we'll see
you on over there hang on one
second